[Music]
so here's the deal i i get a lot of
financial type videos because of the
things i engage with and see yeah you're
an expert and you're relevant yes and a
lot of this advice i'm going to say 99
is just abhorrent financial advice can't
even immediately make blood boil and
it's encouraging a lot of young people
to do a lot of stupid things oh sure and
i can see the future where they're
hopefully calling into our show asking
for help because they did a dumb thing
so i want to play a video and get your
reaction uh and see what you're thinking
so we're going to play a tick tock we're
going to go picture-in-picture here
you ready
very excited roll that beautiful bean
footage here we go
this is the number one real estate
investing strategy that i use to become
a millionaire oh that's a little over
the top method
buy a property for a good price or below
market value that preferably needs some
tlc okay our renovation repair the
properties a lot of jump cuts make it
attractive take the referral tenant will
pay the rent
our rent out the property to a tenant
with good credit oh boy
our
refund
oh boy once you have revenue coming into
your property and you build some equity
you go back to the bank that's it get it
nothing free
repeat this process again with the money
the bank gave you and buy another
revenue property of course
oh here we go
and instagram okay
so first of all there was already a
little too much pep in that interview
and that whole thing
but then she went dick doc at the end
and i completely forgot everything she
said before that well she's got a future
as an actress if the if the real estate
thing doesn't work out a lot of acting
going on there the real estate thing is
not going to work out for her george
well this is a try this is an old
playbook this is old school brought to a
new school platform and here's what it's
doing the young kids out there kids in
their 20s and their 30s my age they're
going this is my path because i am
saddled with student loan debt i'm
living off credit cards i've got a car
payment i need a way to make a lot of
money fast go into debt now even more
debt and then sell it oh no rent it to a
renter didn't repeat the price she
basically said go into debt
have somebody rent it
and then repeat the process go into more
debt
renters have a young dave ramsey
pre-bankruptcy see this is my point this
is what dave did before the tick tock oh
boy you imagine dave doing that video 35
40 with hair some years
sorry
you just visualized it didn't you with a
fake leather jacket and a big chain
maybe dave doing that like all those
years ago
behind him yeah here's the deal what's
the danger in that george now we're
having fun yeah she's a little peppy
well but that's the thing these kids do
this by the way real quick thing she was
i don't know how old she was but it's at
some point there's types of tick tocks
you shouldn't do like there's types of
clothes i shouldn't wear as a 47 year
old man yeah it's the same thing well i
digress we'll talk about the advice here
so our plan as you know if you've
listened to the show for 10 seconds
is to become debt free and stay debt
free because we have found based on lots
of in-depth research with our
millionaire study based on 10 million
people following our plan that the best
path to financial success to building
wealth
is to become debt free and stay debt
free including your mortgage so what
this advice is saying which is
diametrically opposed in case you're
wondering um is saying that you need to
maximize every possible dollar of bank
debt you can get access to
so here's the idea leverage debt out
your eyeballs to have maximum cash flow
and hope that everything works out
perfectly on paper yeah and then you
will in a matter of years have a private
jet that you can pose next to because of
the instagram influencers you follow and
they're driving this drivel
into people's heads okay let's talk
about real practically what could go
wrong with what she could go wrong well
no seriously i'm gonna tee you up you're
the financial expert right sure so you
buy the first house like like uh like uh
uh pepe told us to
okay
and right now it's the top of the market
certainly the united states yeah we've
had you're gonna put as little down as
possible if you're following the stream
as little down as possible everybody
stay with me and let me tell you the
facts we've had a moratorium on
evictions
rentals right we've had a moratorium on
bankruptcies or foreclosures
trump and biden continuing this
that's going to lift here pretty soon
yeah and we're gonna see a lot of bad
stuff hitting the streets and it's gonna
create more supply which what happens
george when we have more supply and less
demand bad things housing prices go down
now you bought a house at the top i'm
just talking now worth a lot less it's
worth a lot less and you still have that
giant mortgage and yet you still have
the mortgage and you still got to pay
for it and you're hoping you're hoping
that you can get a good solid tenant
who's going to pay on time every time
but you may have to drop the rent
because the rent you can't charge what
the rent was at the top of the market
which hurts your profits because you're
stuck paying this giant mortgage payment
because you had nothing down on this
property yeah then what continues to
happen and there's property taxes
there's insurance there's all the
maintenance what happens if you can't
pay that george well foreclosure could
happen oh yeah yeah yeah so now you go
back to instagram and you multiply this
out what do you do what does she got for
you on insta on tick tock after that
happens to you well they know is there
another video they don't talk about when
it goes wrong it's all the promises of
what could be and all the money you
could make in the cash flow that could
happen
could could could could could
then we've made our point we find real
estate advice from the tick tock i think
we're going to see a whole new
generation of the young dave ramsey's
who are filing for bankruptcy and going
well that was a bad move i was leveraged
with 10 properties and then you know
million dollars in debt and i've seen
these tick tocks people bragging that
they're 15 million dollars in debt oh
yeah by the way can i point out
something else on all these platforms
whether it be facebook insta tick tock
anytime you see one of these here's how
you get really stinking rich videos they
always play the part the giant fur
standing next to a private jet real
estate guru they're enticing people into
a trap
and it is all about stuff
every one of those videos by the way i'm
going to step on some toes here i don't
care because every one of those
influences that do this they are selling
an unbelievably extravagant lifestyle
yep they're not selling purpose they're
not selling financial peace they're not
selling
significant contribution to your fellow
man they're not it's a wolf in sheep's
clothes they're selling you is risk it's
all lifestyles of the rich and famous
caviar
all that crap it's a trap
it's a trap
every time it's a trap they're leveraged
out of their eyeballs and they managed
to somehow dodge the bullet and they're
trying to recreate it and they're
getting rich not off of their real
estate strategies they're getting rich
off of their courses that tell you how
to do it like they oh there i've gone
into oh man i stepped in yeah riled up
stepped in it there a little bit i'm not
mentioning names here's the problem you
see a video like that and you're a
20-something year old who's strapped
with debt who doesn't have a great
income he knocks like a fastlane baby
and they go absolutely
they get starry-eyed they only see the
upside and they're delusional about the
downside by the way there's no hard work
in that it's just go down and get a loan
and then play out this seven step
process that johnny richboy told me on
instagram and do a bunch of cash out
refis to stay in debt for the rest of
your life
it's it's just a it's a it's a giant
motivational trap
don't do this guys please please please
if you see financial advice on take doc
that sounds too good to be true it is
it's a trap and if you follow the trends
you will fall for the traps that's what
i say ken
george you said it well thank you say it
again if you follow the trends you will
fall for the traps
and that that goes with crypto and nfts
and zero down real estate you name it
there's always a new trend out there
that's the newest get rich quick scheme
and i'll tell you read through proverbs
i don't care if you're a person of faith
or not read through proverbs it speaks
against all these get-rich-quick schemes
that we're seeing today